[Music]
hey what's up oh my god we've been split
in half
no this is a creative choice by zack
snyder
he feels that this is gonna i'm sorry
yes we thought we'd be similarly
uh sloppy um can you find the dead pixel
on the screen
uh you winner gets a t-shirt uh yes
welcome to honest trail commentaries
where we will be talking about this
week's honest trailer give your
behind-the-scenes thoughts
check out some deleted scenes respond to
comments and questions from viewers like
you so keep them going in the chat and
we'll tease you with next week's honest
trailer
um i'm rushing this intro but you know
what wasn't rushed
army of the dead a film that really took
its time
a two and a half hour zombie movie uh uh
portending the
arrival of three more zombie movies
series on netflix directed by
screen junkies favorite director zachary
j snyder i don't know his middle name um
this was a film this was a lot of film
and i actually i you know
joking aside i was ready to love this
one man
i loved his dawn of the dead remake that
is my favorite movie of his by a long
shot and it's like all right
all the dc stuff the warner brothers is
behind him
back to basics snyder like let's just
have a really nihilistic zombie movie
and it was almost but not quite that for
me
um we can talk about it more in detail
but what's your what's
your guys's broad strokes thumbs up
thumbs down review of this movie
um i wanted a carnival and i was given
like a state fair
i love the state fair they always have
such large pigs
yeah and you can pet him and touch him
but can i can i
throw maybe more of a county i feel like
we're at more of a county fair
a state fair it's a bad analogy for me
because the county fair you get smash
mouth like it's always a good time you
get you get a fried
uh yeah i feel like this is straight up
oc
county fair territory we're in right now
i love the oc counterfeit anyways
we'll call it a bound house um i just
you know i like i if you're gonna go all
out i want the all out and the zombie
tiger
gave me a lot of expectation that i feel
like it wasn't uh
it didn't it didn't give me in terms of
man that zombie tiger sure liked laying
down before a fight
you're like running up and then and then
kind of turning around
yeah so that's kind of my broad strokes
thoughts as i wish it was a little i'm
glad there were no jump scares because i
do not like jump scares
um but i wish that there was just a
little more you're gonna give me vegas
you're gonna give me zombies i want a
little more
just wildness than what i think i saw
yeah yeah
it just it it feels like i mean my
number one complaint about
the movie that really like bothered me
throughout and kind of took me out of
even the things i normally would have
found fun
was the blurry it was yes how constantly
playing around with the depth
of field like he's trying to like
he's trying to direct our eye even
within a shot so if there's a person
talking to another person
he's only going to focus on the person
he wants you to pay attention to
at the time and that's obnoxious like
let me look where i want to look and
it wastes the largely impressive
production design like
they created this bombed out zombie
vegas
world for these characters to have this
adventure in
and it looks really cool and we like
barely get to see it because
he's constantly like only focusing on
the person in the foreground and it just
looks like they're in
you know glaucoma world and we can't see
any make out anything in the background
and it's a real shame so that that
bothered me in terms of the filmmaking
but it also just feels like it's just
not fun like
it it should it's a the opening credit
sequence where we see the zombies
take over vegas is super fun like
stripper zombies and
guys old gamblers getting their toupees
snatched off by zombies like
elvis zombies like i feel like that's
what the promise of a vegas zombie movie
is and then the rest of the movie
doesn't really deliver on that promise
at all
it's just like a adventure movie in a
zombie
city it doesn't feel like it has that
humor
i mean i have a pitch for for the remake
um
which is maybe that's when you set the
zombie heist is like when they're still
cordoning off vegas and like it would
make maybe more sense for the government
to
nuke it immediately instead of letting
it marinate for several months
um so like a bomb's gonna come down on
vegas they're surrounding the city
that's when you send in your team of
merchants i like that i like that
yeah i mean in a world building sense
the idea that they're just going to like
surround vegas with shipping containers
and just be like
all right zombies you you do you we're
gonna just like hang out like i don't
it just doesn't seem very realistic and
it also seems like i think we've learned
from
the last year like you're not just gonna
be
like if people have already figured out
because there's a coyote who knows the
way
in and out like and is ferrying people
in and out of the zombie zone like
it would have taken three days for
zombieism to spread around the world
like there's no way
we would have realistically contained it
to vegas for months
anywho we have so many more thoughts
about this movie uh uh let's roll the
trailer because i think
i think it'll give us ample opportunity
to talk about
what sure didn't make it in because i
got lost oh man
[Music]
from the love child of joe rogan and
michael bay
comes a zack snyder film with no one at
the studio telling him how to write a
script
easy peasy japanese how to direct a
performance
and i'll probably die or how to focus
the camera
focus focus please focus
focus now so pause i mean this is like
uh snyder unleashed right like this this
is the
pure undiluted uh vision where
like maybe this shows you that sometimes
not all studio
notes are bad because i feel like
netflix if they were a traditional
studio they'd be like
zack buddy like this is a this is a
zombie heist
vegas movie like it's not the justice
league you don't have to have like
juggle
17 iconic characters at once they should
be in they should be out
probably before 120 minutes
maybe you can cut some of this right
like should this have been a shorter
movie
yeah i don't know that we needed an hour
to get the team together
right no there's there's unnecessary
setup with the team
and they don't end up being distinct
characters anyway like if you're gonna
spend a lot of time setting up the crew
but then it's like oh we really know a
lot and care about the members of the
crew
great i'm i'm with that but they end up
just being kind of generic badass
characters anyway so it's not like time
well spent
but netflix is just in the they're in
the content business they're content
companies they just want
content to your point the it feels a
little bit the
the i'm gonna mess around with the focus
thing the whole time
feels a bit like the i'm gonna do the
whole movie in four by three
justice league decision where it's like
sometimes these decisions kind of feel
like
a whim like he he just likes the way
this looks and
i'm gonna do the whole movie like that
and that is an opportunity where maybe a
studio would come in to be like do we
do we really wanna do this tentpole
movie this way
like think about like even just giving
him that moment
of pause to think about whether the
whole movie needs to have this
elaborating this imax but everyone's
going to be watching it
at home right or like i get that it's
yeah and i i get that in one scene using
depth of field to like throw off people
or
for a surprise or whatever can work but
every scene using it is just too much
and is
like annoying like i don't think like
sometimes it might help to have people
in
i think that could have helped if like
danielle you were saying like there
weren't jump scares but
this could have been used as like a
constant jump-scare device if they did
want to make this like a claustrophobic
movie but then it's not a claustrophobic
movie it's basically an action movie
it's definitely not a heist movie yeah
and i mean it serves against the epic
scale like
you want more of the background to be
clear because you want to give us a
sense for this adventure happening in
this crazy setting
it runs counter to his purpose and
that's a thing i think a studio note
would
like warner brothers would have brought
that up at some point like
hey maybe focus more all right keep
going
oh also that song is about the irish
republican army zack you don't need to
use
we'll get to that okay focus
focus army of the dead
zombies have taken over las vegas thanks
to roadhead gone wrong
[Applause]
and now the whole spirit halloween the
paintball field
with the government from idiocracy all
set to drop a nuke
drop in the nuke on the fourth would be
quote really cool
and actually kind of patriotic if you
think about it there's just a few days
left for a billionaire to hire some
mercs to rob his own casino
but don't worry that dumb plan is just
cover for the military's even dumber
plan
power to control your own zombie army
which is his cover for one woman
i mean look they're all dumb plant it's
dumb plans all the way down
right but for the billionaire for nobody
to ask during the like
orientation like hey we're robbing your
own safe
um what's the code
[Laughter]
you own this place uh booby traps want
to tell us about them
yeah well my favorite booby trap thing
is okay
you're designing a casino vault and it's
going to be
robbery proof and at one point if a
person doesn't know to turn off the
booby traps
a wall just slams shut on them killing
anyone who's there
would you then have that wall retract
thus revealing your vault like
like it's there to slam one person to
death and then
it turns itself off like and then
somebody's gonna reset
the wall should stay shut until you're
like verifying that the thieves are gone
like also it's just like you know when
that wall retracts you're gonna have
body viscera goo to clean up like it's
just a stupid
plan regardless like whose job is it to
clean up after that goes off but
uh like yeah like there's so much like
that that it's almost pointless to to
cat like
i feel like there's so much craziness
that you just have to be like all right
it's all just crazy
yeah it's just um i mean it's
complicated for the sake of being
complicated because it's like
you also have the military who wants to
capture a zombie live
right right now they've already
completely cordoned off
vegas and they control all of las vegas
and the checkpoints and they have these
camps and stuff like that
is it really necessary to piggyback on
like a
group of like one last shot heist
veterans to go
i mean a zombie or can you just send in
seal team
z or whatever and and come back out but
also
please recall the opening of the movie
which is the military
moving a zombie from one facility to
another anyway
so they so they already had a zombie
they they should already have tissue
samples whatever data they need
it started with them they're they're
like trying to get a
specimen of their own creation right
like shouldn't they have logs of
everything they did
that they could just replicate right and
then on okay on top of that on top of
that
um they so the military like ha or the
some kind of public private partnership
they have like the uh they have martin
they have like the double
the double agent like sent along for the
ride where his true mission is to get a
zombie head
the the most obvious betray like he like
shows up like
hey i'm here to betray the mission at
the last second they're like hey i don't
trust you we're gonna fight the whole
time but
please come along the craziest part is
give you a perfect opportunity to betray
us
there was zero point to him betraying
them he got what he wanted he has the
zombie head in the bag
they are actually just they continue
with your life
they've made a perfectly reasonable deal
that works like
these guys want the money he wants the
zombie head neither one has any
vested interest in stopping the other
one yeah
yeah why why screw each other over like
just leave with your head
yeah it makes no sense at all it's just
like a betrayal just because they wanted
to add that obstacle
but it's a two and a half hour movie you
don't need any more obstacles
crazy oh okay all right keep going
which is his cover for one woman's even
dumber plan to avoid raising some kids
in case anything happens to me in the
next few days just make sure the kids
make it out to barstow okay
i'm coming with you would you just cover
for one company's even dumber plan to
launch an entire shared universe
off one average zombie movie hey
remember when we had way too much zombie
stuff
like five years ago cool cool cool
if you want to pull off a great heist
you're gonna need the perfect crew
gear up with one damaged badass one
damaged badass
one damaged bad ass one damaged badass
one damaged badass one damaged badass
a couple of fun-loving badasses and the
world's most obvious traitor
i don't trust you i don't trust that guy
i don't trust any of these people but
especially you
but no crew is truly complete without a
show stealing comic relief
well pause before we get into the tarot
stuff i mean the crew is actually a
perfect fit for the heist plan which is
just a very dumb
smash and grab it's just like
you assemble this diverse group of
characters for a heist movie because
the robbery's gonna take so many
different skills you're gonna have to
fool people then you're gonna need the
acrobat guy then you're gonna need the
getaway driver then
i guess tig is the getaway driver but
they always have these different very
specialized roles but theirs is just
like
shoot shoot shoot open money carry money
upstairs
fly away yeah you needed an influencer
you needed an influence yeah the
influence that's such a weird
every crew needs an influencer yeah it's
it's right it just it feels like
there's so much he's got he there are
things about this scenario that zack zad
is very interested in but
none of them are the heist like all of
them are like
the hierarchy of zombie society
like he's fascinated by that and we get
a lot of time spent on that that doesn't
end up really paying off like
here are the alphas and here the drones
and they take them here and then the
humans go here
and it's just like all doesn't really
add up and like all these other kinds of
zombies and
like these zombies can't get you know
they'll get rained on and come back to
like uh all sorts of things it's very
dare i say and i hate to put these in
the same breath because this is a much
superior film
and much more enjoyable but very dark
universe mummy vibes
yeah well right it's just like we right
there's so much material that's
obviously being like
put in i mean i think we mentioned it
later but
there is a robot zombie that goes
not explained right i'm not crazy right
that's in there
yeah you see a zombie face pulled away
and there's like a robot face right
there's several robot
zombies there's a couple robot zombies
that's right look at that we'll get to
that one we'll get to that
but like that's what i mean like like
that's the time i feel like you need to
spend some of that giving us a little
bit more of like
okay there's these four steps to the
heist and these are the people we need
to help us pull it off
yeah and now let's talk let's talk tig
keep going knocks those rolls out of the
park
like critique nataro because when you
get a pro
like tig nataro you just sit back and
let tig
nataro do what tig nataro
does best appeal to a younger audience
experience a film i thought this was
pretty seamless
i was like there's like two shots with a
big
group of people together where you can
kind of see that she doesn't
like the plane you know she's just like
not quite lined up the way a real person
would be
but i think he did himself a huge favor
of there's a lot of just like
one you know there's a lot of like shot
reverse shot kind of setups anyway
because they're in these tight spaces so
it it
it's pretty seamless for the most part
like it does seem like her and batista
are in
a helicopter together even though they
never were
yeah um and i think that she's she's an
improvement i mean
she made me laugh i can't say the same
for crystalia
i don't know that he's ever made me
laugh but take made me laugh in this a
whole bunch i really
i really enjoyed it yeah yeah i think
she's she's one of the best
characters which is like crazy because
you think of
chemistry on set as being part of what
would make
like especially a comic relief kind of
character work and she was saying these
lines
to nobody on a green screen but well i
think that was fun and it kind of fit
almost because her character is one
who's like i don't know what's going on
i don't really care what's going on i'm
just kind of
gonna be chilling over here commenting
on stuff so it was uh it was very meta
um i feel like she's legit made a case
for like
you can cast her as like a badass in
your action ensemble now like i feel
like this cements like i could see
tignataro and more
of these kinds of roles for sure yeah
which is crazy but
yeah it's not expected you'll have to
see it i'm in yeah
all right keep going about broke
veterans stealing money during a zombie
apocalypse
that somehow not a commentary on
anything we're not in america anymore
haven't you heard no we've got all that
cool news
technically makes it an even freer
country right
whatever where the only theme is the
zero the team gives about each other
don't go nowhere team the broader guy in
one side of them had to leave him
what are we doing just go let's go
oh reboir come on leave her she's dead
don't screw me just something i thought
of like in seeing her it's like
why is that character french why is
there a french lady
that goes in and out of the of the uh
uh why is the refugee camp
directly next to zombie vegas
that doesn't seem smart no not really it
seems like a bad idea yeah
well it's it's just like i mean the
whole idea of the quarantine
is just row of shipping containers like
that's it
like there's no like there are there are
guards but like a few of them like it's
not you would think that this would be
heavily guarded like at least as hard to
get onto as like a random military base
all the dumb government decisions though
are sort of justified because it tells
you that like oh we've got
you know president camacho in this
universe right so yes
that does go a long way that yeah it's
all it was like this happened in an
already like dystopian version of
our world i guess all right keep going
just go so that's a pretty common theme
for you
leaving people behind but there's no
time for social satire when there's so
many awesome ideas to introduce
and never follow up on like robot
zombies
what's their deal who knows rain zombies
you should see what happens when it
rains for a few hours they'll come back
to life
we should see that but we don't zombie
sex
how's that possible tbd and the awesome
zombie killing saw that keeps getting
teased are you ready to play
don't ever touch my soul again okay
check out
here it comes it's zombie saw in time
wait what they only use it to make a
door it's under saving the good stuff
for the prequel the sequel the anime
prequel or the snyder cut
i mean that is what the movie needed
more of is like um
uh the the saw and like the improvised
um what's that
video game franchise dead rising where
it's like oh you're in vegas
uh or like his dawn of the dead remake
where they make like the school bus
zombie killing machine
like it needed more fun blowing up
zombie devices
no am i crazy yeah no i definitely
wanted more saw i was definitely bummed
that we didn't get to see more of that
at all
yeah it's like a b movie that's trying
to pretend that it's an a movie and it's
like nobody
wants nobody wants that we don't want
like a prestige zombie movie we want
like
the outrageous over-the-top cartoonish
ridiculous thing
and like especially if you're selling it
as heist zombie movie
in vegas like it should be the i guess
you know it's like well danielle would
say like at the very top like it should
be the full-on balls to the wall
most extreme version of itself and you
could feel it holding back
both i think because there's these four
other projects that they have to service
but also like
i don't know it just feels like it's
weirdly holding back in a
in a way and it it shouldn't and like i
don't know why it would
i want them to like use the the
craziness of vegas
more as like a as a backdrop like they
they had a shootout in a casino but like
have a fight on like the the blue man
group stage
they have to go right there's like
zombies on the roller coaster at the top
of the stratosphere or something yeah
you know like what's happening inside
circus circus right now like go
excalibur or whatever
yeah get some zombie jousting hanging
off of those aerial things off a cirque
du soleil with like a gun and a saw
how dope would that be yeah i think here
comes all of magic mike double xl live
review
thrusting in our direction yeah like
yeah i don't i don't know
what on earth would cause you to hold
back on something like this it's army of
the dead in vegas just
just go for it man all right keep going
for some classic snyder that may not be
his best zombie flick
but it's got a great opening credit
sequence then a bunch of overlong
nonsense that's not as fun as it should
be especially when you put a better idea
for a movie
in the movie there's another team of
grave robbers it could be us
in another timeline and we're caught in
some
infinite loop of fighting and dying i
would much rather watch that story
any idea what the hell we're hauling
amelia earhart
what a lie or that one open a new food
truck
sneaking hearts and grilled cheese
sandwiches or that one
starring dave bautista looking like he's
holding in a sneeze
pause i'm glad we landed on that because
he has that expression
[Laughter]
yeah it's look i love dave bautista as
an actor i really do
like i'm a fan uh i i think he's great
at blade runner i think he's great in
the guardians movies i like him
inspector
a lot uh but yeah in this one he's just
he he doesn't i don't know he's being
asked to to do
a mood that just doesn't come as
naturally to him and his
response is looking like he has to hold
the he has to sneeze
[Music]
um he also is great at making glasses
look very
very small yes i think normal size
glasses look tiny
that would have been a note for me is
like is could we have an excuse to put
batista in another pair of tiny glasses
uh they did i feel like but i think
they're normal-sized glasses he just
makes them look tiny
no right yes human glasses for dave
batista are
tiny glasses all right keep playing
chris deleted psalms of anarchy
tommy wiseau you saw nothing
i guess flue had a scheduling conflict
zom influencer
eight simple rules for eviscerating my
teenage daughter
get over here and run my casino for me
tricky martin
lily vegas multi-pass and
i'm dead
world war
[Music]
it's very mad magazine of us you know
you have a guy on his way to steal 200
million dollars in cash would have a
better plan for carrying it all up to
the roof
i mean i know he's shaped like an upside
down triangle and all but that's four
thousand four hundred pounds dude
yeah that's a thing like other movies
where there's a heist
they very often will have to that'll be
part of the challenge to the team
is like and then how do we move all of
that money out it's so heavy
and this is what they just like we carry
it to the roof we we haul it ourselves
because we're badasses
they just don't even engage with that
question oh
not the smartest movie but not dumb
enough i don't think
that's that i i had in my notes
um like with the saw like that that you
know i
i thought we could put that simpsons
beat in of like oh but look at that guy
with the saw he hasn't done anything yet
you just know when he does it's gonna be
cool and like i
really was waiting for the payoff to put
that in and then it never
never happened yeah oh well well uh
the book of saw part two let's get into
what we cut but first thank you all for
watching
please like please subscribe hit that
bell if you agree with us and even if
you don't
uh you can come back on here every week
and argue with us online because we will
be responding to your comments
after these deleted scenes
hey does this movie ever say what
happens to those kids and their mom in
the end
no couldn't find time in two and a half
hours to wrap that up huh
cool cool starring
death becomes her a real head turner
we'll fix it in post glenn dancing
man chris angel got old saw no saw
das goof delete your account i volunteer
his tribute i just want to
start just so other people can enjoy um
we were talking on slack uh
last week about chris angel's new
restaurant in vegas
yeah it's like c-a-b-l-p
yeah three meals of the day three
squares a day breakfast lunch and pizza
and and when he says c-a-b-l-p we don't
mean
capital c period a period no it's no
c capital c lowercase a-b-l-p
the worst name for a restaurant but we
were just pointing out
like mind eats or mine treats or like
right there mouth freak yeah couldn't be
more obvious
you've got a famous name associated with
you already
you idiots chris angel's mind treats but
no
yeah how perfect is that that that's it
that's the name of the restaurant
cowboy yeah i was always i was saying it
had to be
him drunk texting his business manager
and then that's just like refusing to
admit he made a mistake
the next day yeah it's it's like
just also not a guy i associate with
like eating food
or yeah like why like the magician to
food
assuming that i'm gonna follow you on
that journey is is a weird present i
would be
terrified um if every waiter
is a is a close-up magic person oh yeah
no i don't like that at all
but they have to right to make it make
sense like at least they have to do at
least one like if your tops are actually
over here
if it's not your waiter there's at least
close-up magic happening
in the restaurant like somebody's coming
over to your table and doing something
messy like a serenade
like if you want to propose it's like is
this your ring
[Laughter]
but it's like in the guy's nipple
yeah they're not there's nothing there's
not a person going around selling
flowers for your date it's like
endless handkerchiefs
that's not mine freaky enough though
that it has to be like a bunch of like
uh
salamanders like bag of salamanders yeah
matches for your date
we'll do our next live show uh from
kabul
see you there okay keep going
tribute sergeant daughter one last big
scorpion
there's something i don't trust about
that guy coyote
ugly and mc scat cat
and barfield fear and looting
in las vegas 11.
zack snyder presents zack snyder's army
of the dead
from the book of snyder i want that
i like that one too all right uh
some deleted scenes for you very good um
but we're not the only ones talking
uh y'all been talking in the chat uh
here's from barbara johnson is this the
beginning of another wave of zombie
movies slash shows or the last gas i
have to think this is the last gasp
or it's the start of its own little
pocket zombie universe of
just snyder zombie stuff right because
walking dead is not going strong or or
am i
out of the loop i mean the original
walking dead is
wrapping up it's got one more season but
they've got several spin-offs already
going and
maybe movies i i feel like zombies are
just like with us now
like i don't i feel like we that that
trend crested
like we don't have as much zombie
content as we did during the peak
but i think every few years somebody's
gonna try to like
reinvent the zombie wheel you know like
that's it's just that there's a
permanent interest in the
undead at this point
yeah um okay louis valenzuela writes if
each subsequent sweet sequel did follow
a trend of using a different genre to do
a zombie movie what would you want
um well i feel like
you're going straight romka straight to
the rom-com huh straight to the wrong
zom-rom-com
is that zomcom is that between two
zombies or a human and a zombie well
there have been a few
sort of attempts right like um life
after beth and warm bodies
yeah oh is it a meat cute m-e-a-t
[Laughter]
[Music]
i see what you did there i feel like a
buddy
action like a midnight run where it's
like a regular
human and a zombie and they're like
handcuffed to each other
and they gotta like get through this
ordeal uh to get to the end you know
okay um i mean i'm psyched for them to
adapt uh
marvel zombies cause i just think it's
so
messed up and and fun to watch them all
team up to just eat
each other and tons of people and like
and like it's like captain america so he
knows what he's doing is wrong but he
can't stop eating spider-man um it's
really effed up i love it i feel like
they're gonna have to send that one to
hulu i don't feel like that's gonna make
it on disney plus
uh but if if snyder's make it i don't
think it'll matter what other genre it
is because
this didn't this was not a heist movie
even though they
this was a robbery movie they took money
out of the safe that's kind of the thing
with the zombie genre though is like it
it overwhelms whatever other you know
whatever else you mix it with you know
like it's the overpowering
flavor so like it's hard to sustain your
other genre when you've got
zombies going on yeah um okay
london rowlet writes i'm gonna i'm
actually broadening this question a
little if you could insert tignataro
into any other zombie show slash movie
what would it be and how i'm gonna say
any other show or movie
what who you who are you taking out and
take and digging in
oh um
romeo and juliet and i want her to play
tibblet oh right she's the place of uh
leguizamo
yeah yeah was like a table that was oh
yeah
that was yeah sorry yeah you're right
correct the prince of cats tignataro
yeah
this is a good question i'm gonna go
ahead and say
uh titanic the billy zane roll
oh i'd like to see take notaro try her
hand at like
upper upper crust uh you know
how dare you put your hands on my fiance
that guy and it's dignitarian
uh i'll do my usual stock answer which
is turtle from entourage
her joining vinnie and the boys is
exactly what that show needed
um okay and then finally uh cody smith
asks will kovitt have a lasting effect
on the horror genre
i think it will in the sense that we
know how people will believably react to
a pandemic which is
half the people will do nothing and
pretend it doesn't exist so i guess it
makes
zombie movies more realistic
yeah i mean i think we're already seeing
like we're gonna see more
movies about being isolated feeling
claustrophobic
there's a place you can't leave there
you're you're unsafe around a lot of
people
i feel like those ideas just just rest i
mean obviously that was already
a lot of themes of horror before the
pandemic but i think those ideas
really resonate even more so with people
now and so filmmakers are going to
try to latch on to that however they can
yeah yeah i mean this movie sort of had
coveted implications in it but it was
made pre
right there is one there is one scene
where they
link like oh the government is requiring
like temperature checks and all of these
public
safety protocols and the cops are using
it
for like underhanded like as excuses to
mess with people and be prejudiced
against people and that did feel like it
was kind of intended as commentary but
of course this was made in 2019 before
he could have known about it so it's
just a coincidence yeah
accidental genius much like todd
phillips joker
but that's a whole other discussion
uh i think that's all the time we we're
not going to oversteer welcome like army
of the dead
uh we're going to get out of here uh is
it just a just a tight 30.
um but we will be back next week um for
something that
finally something that i'm liking a lot
so it'll be
more fun to talk about but harder to
write jokes about but we will be back
for another very powerful uh piece of
content yeah call it content um lon
danielle thank you as always
audience y'all are the best please come
back because we will
next tuesday for another episode of
honest trailer commentaries see you then
[Music]
bye
you